felixstowe suele ser el mayor puerto de
mercancías del reino unido- ahora está
detenido cerca de 2.000 trabajadores
portuarios iniciaron este domingo una
huelga de ocho días que podría paralizar
el tráfico de mercancías en el país la
acción se produce después de dos días de
huelga de los trabajadores ferroviarios
para reclamar mejores salarios tienen
que encontrar otro camino porque
perturban a todo el país inmensamente me
alegro de que la gente tenga la
oportunidad de exponer su punto de vista
pero claro los que sufrimos somos
nosotros no los que van a trabajar en
sus limusinas y taxis negros el viernes
fueron los trabajadores del metro de
londres quienes entraron en huelga
reclaman entre otras cosas una subida
salarial ante la galopante inflación en
el reino unido- la subida de los precios
superó el 10 por ciento en julio un
récord en 40 años
por primera vez desde la década de 1950
es probable que los británicos se
enfrenten a restricciones alimentarias
cortes de electricidad y escasez de
calefacción es por el momento las
negociaciones entre el gobierno y los
sindicatos
siguen en un punto muerto y la protesta
podría seguir creciendo
seguiremos hasta conseguir un acuerdo
que apoyen nuestros miembros estamos en
esta disputa porque no tenemos otra
opción estamos siendo atacados por las
empresas y por el gobierno un conflicto
social que tendrá que resolver el
próximo primer ministro en la carrera la
conservadora listos y rígidos unac ros
la favorita es conocida por su
liberalismo económico y se ha
comprometido a presentar una legislación
para restringir aún más el derecho de
huelga